moving on now to the aftermath of that
racist attack in buffalo which killed 10
people and caused shock sadness and
outrage all across the country president
biden visited the community yesterday
and called the mass shooting an act of
quote domestic terrorism he urged
americans to reject white supremacy and
the conspiracy theories that inspired
the alleged gunman
and the president spent more than an
hour with families of the victims our
national correspondent duncan was there
for the president's visit has been there
since sunday in fact rica good morning
to you how did people respond to the
president's speech
good morning to you all at the table the
president was needed here in terms of
the families who've lost loved ones but
there was a feeling a mixed feeling if
you will about his visit uh take some
video here that we're going to show you
hundreds of people were gathered outside
of that community center where he spoke
to the families of those killed some
were outside praying and kneeling in a
moment of reflection while others were
screaming and chanting get off your
knees and stand up and fight
white supremacy is a poison
it's a poison
speaking to a grieving community tuesday
an emotional president biden condemned
the racist ideology of the accused
gunman who killed 10 black people at
this buffalo supermarket i call on all
americans to reject the lie and i
condemn those who spread the lie for
power
political gain
and for profit the president was calling
out those who have pushed the great
replacement theory the belief apparently
shared by the accused shooter that white
americans are being systematically
replaced by immigrants and minorities
roberta drury 32 beloved daughter and
sister the president named each of the
victims andre mcneil
53
worked at a restaurant went to buy his
three-year-old son a birthday cake after
a speech the president hugged macneal's
three-year-old son and gave him a
presidential challenge coin his family
said he's too young to understand what
happened to his father my uncle's story
and what happened to him wasn't just
kicked under a rug like it meant nothing
because it meant a lot theon and linda
elliott are andre mcneil's brother and
niece for people who are angry and are
talking about
there needs to be retaliation what do
you say to that i say do i say you're
only dividing don't do that that's not
good every person that is of caucasian
or black or whatever is not evil many
families are still recovering from that
horrific shooting eight-year-old london
thomas was with her parents when shots
rang out i was scared for my mom because
i thought something happened to her she
and her dad split up from her mom and
rushed to the back of the store they
barricaded themselves inside a mill
cooler until they could be rescued i
didn't know what's going on i just like
followed my dad her mom julie hartwell
is stuck wondering the same questions
many in this community are facing this
morning what are we going to do
after this
that's all i'm worried about
because my kid has to grow up
here
what is the next step
to prevent this from even happening
anymore
president biden acknowledged that
there's little he can do to take on gun
reform when it comes through passing
anything through executive action he
said that he needed to convince congress
to go back to what he was able to help
pass as a u.s senator in the 90s
referring to that 10-year ban on assault
weapons which some have deemed
controversial and have questioned
whether or not something like that would
actually make a difference when it comes
to the mass shootings that have been
committed over the last decade
nate
thank you so much we know that the pain
is just starting and the healing will
begin hopefully soon